[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission de débat qui passe au crible
l'actualité politique chaque semaine au
sommaire l'union européenne et la
souveraineté nationale entre la remise
en cause de la primauté du droit
européen par la pologne et plusieurs
candidats à la présidentielle qui
fustige la lourdeur des règles des
vingt-sept ces dernières affaiblissent
tels les pays membres union européenne
et souveraineté nationale sont elles
réellement compatibles c'est le débat de
la semaine alexis poulin et jacques de
guillebon vous livreront ensuite leur
point de vue sur une actualité politique
qui pourrait faire la une dans le monde
d'après mais d'abord serait ce le retour
des gilet jaune partout en france
plusieurs ronds points sont de nouveau
occupé en signe de protestation contre
des mesures gouvernementales comme la
récente prime de 100 euros annoncés par
jean castex pour pallier à
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
jugée insuffisante ou encore le
prolongement du pas salutaire alors
messieurs ouvrons un débat selon vous
quel candidat pouvait tirer parti du
retour des gilet jaune
[Musique]
bonjour jacques bonjour alexis alors
quel candidat pour être répartis du
retour des gilet jaune
évidemment il ya d'abord jean luc
mélenchon avec cette idée de révolution
populaire qui revient il avait été un
des politiques les plus loquaces sur ce
mouvement d gilet jaune il ya aussi
marine le pen qui avait essayé de faire
de l'entrisme de ce côté là et puis
florian philippot surfant sur l'anti
passe et les manifestations du samedi
pourrait lui aussi en profiter en tant
que candidat mais ça reste hypothétique
le retour il est loin d'être acté un
retour des gilets jaunes oui le retour
du gilet jaune est loin d'être acté et
le rapport des politiques avec eux
encore plus moi je dirais comme vous
j'ajouterai peut-être eric zemmour qui
essaye de se greffer là-dessus quoiqu'il
ait pas tout à fait compris encore je
pense que prometic de ces français quand
il dit que le pouvoir d'achat par les
pouvoir d'achat c'est mépriser les
français je pense que c'est un rôle à
tiques il n'empêche que le lendemain il
parle du permis à points dont on sait
que c'était avec la limitation 80 km
heure une des revendications des
premiers jd je ne dis à trois ans après
ce gilet jaune existe une vocation qui
existe qui a été mis sous le boisseau
pendant l'année et demie où les deux ans
de virus mail en question n'ont pas été
réglés il faudrait simplement pas qu'il
le répète comme disait marx et
l'histoire se répète toujours de manière
comique la seconde fois qui devient la
caricature d'eux mêmes et qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à formuler encore une
fois leurs revendications
moi je crois qu'effectivement c'était un
mouvement qui a surpris tout le monde
notamment la classe politique à l'époque
où il arrive et pourtant on comprend
c'est ce ras-le-bol de cette france
invisible qui travaillent qui fait ou
qu'on lui demande et qui ne gagnent pas
qui perd systématiquement qui perd dans
la mondialisation qui perd en pouvoir
d'achat qui perd aussi en horizon de
futures et la réponse a été la violence
un rappelez-vous ça a été une répression
violente des manifestations puis laisse
bouffe le grand débat où emmanuel macron
se met en scène et vole la parole
publique les cahiers de doléances eux
ont été enterrés au sous sol de la
bibliothèque nationale de france en l2
et là on se rend compte que les
problèmes soulevés par les jaunes sont
aggravées à la fois par la crise
sanitaire mais par la politique des
mollets de macron donc on a davantage de
précarité davantage de peur de l'avenir
davantage de problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat de l'essence est plus cher
encore qu'à l'époque où les généraux ne
commence et on a le même gouvernement et
on a les mêmes réponses et on ça ne peut
pas continuer comme ça et le problème
effectivement des gilet jaune c'est de
dire que là ils refusent toujours
l'incarnation politique à dire que les
politiques finalement sont dangereux ou
ne peut pas leur faire confiance parce
que c'est un système qui nous ment dans
on est du côté de l'abstentionnisme plus
tôt et puis l'autre problème c'est
l'absence de stratégie c'est à dire que
là on a des gilet jaune qui appellent à
reprendre les ronds-points méprendre les
ronds points c'est pas ça qui fait qu'on
prend le pouvoir non c'est certain ils
essayent de se rappeler au bon souvenir
des politiques et les quelles politiques
n'ont jamais eu de réponses
structurelles pour les populations comme
ce qu'il la connaissait pas ils ont
entendu qu'elle existe et s'il la voit
de loin mais alors qu'on a des plans
banlieues tout le temps cette population
saisie de nous on n'a pas de réponse
structurelle lausanne une prime de 100
euros et une indemnité je sais plus
comment elle s'appelle des classes
moyennes interface voilà qui est quelque
chose que les gens prennent comme un
mépris encore une fois c'est à dire que
c'est d'une population on la connaît
cette population périphériques qui fait
que vous vous dites les sales boulots
les premiers de corvée comme ils
s'appellent et qui voit que la
croissance revient mais qu'ils n'en
voient pas les fruits toutefois pas la
répartition chez eux et je pense que
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour le
gouvernement de rester sur cette
position là et de dire regardez ça
repart 6% de croissance le pays est
merveilleux tout va bien se passer sauf
que ces gens là ne le voit pas on le
voit on en reparlera peut-être tout à
l'heure mais dans les hôpitaux aussi si
on manque de personnel soignant c'est
parce que ces gens sont mal traités sont
mal payés pareil chez les professeurs
mais là-dessus anne hidalgo avait un
petit peu raison pour une fois en dix
ans n'ont pas forcément de faire le
doublé lors le salaire des professeurs
en tout cas de l'augmenter ce sont des
gens qui sont ou qui sont ni dans les
marges et qui restent avec leur leurs
salaires qui sont misérables si on peut
dire par rapport au
ccc d'ailleurs l'aveu du gouvernement à
ce chèque énergie c'est de dire plus de
38 millions de foyers finalement gagne
2000 euros et on ne fait rien pour
changer ça c'est à dire que vous avez
d'un côté les syndicats patronaux comme
le medef qu'il faut surtout pas
augmenter les salaires ça va faire
augmenter la station l'inflation et les
lads de toute façon et c'est pas les
primes qui vont permettre de d'arrêter
cette paupérisation croissante de la
population française et aussi le fait
que les métiers qui sont ce ceux du soin
ce doux on s'occupe de l'humain
éducation santé sont sous-valorisés de
dévaloriser on n'arrive pas à recruter
dans ces métiers là et encore plus de
démissions des professeurs cette année
sous jean michel blanquer pareil pour
les soignants on n'a jamais vu autant de
démission alors on met ça sur le dos de
la crise sanitaire pour les soignants
non il ya une maladie chronique en
france du service public on a un
gouvernement après gouvernement saper le
service public et le gilet jaune c'est
cette france périphérique ces personnes
loin justement du service public en dix
ans on ne peut pas dire parce qu'il faut
faire maintenant 80 km heure pour aller
voir un médecin ça va et la réponse aux
déserts médicaux ckoi et bien l'évidence
c'est plus de robots plus de
téléconsultation non c'était pas ça il
faut plus de bras il faut il faut des
gens qui travaillent qui s'occupe du
soin une société qui est progressiste si
elle doit l'être alors elle s'occupe des
gens ne s'occupe pas des profits et
aujourd'hui on voit bien c'est cette
folie financière qui fait que les
milliardaires ont encore augmenté leur
fortune et les plus pauvres sont rentrés
dans davantage de deux précarité et le
gouvernement pris entre ces deux feux
qui a choisi son camp ne prévoit jamais
subie à la clé de l'énergie chaque mois
est prévue mais annoncé là il nous
explique que c'est le la mondialisation
qui veut ça qu'on n'y peut rien mais
c'est le travail de son gouvernement de
les voir ça le prix de logements pareil
c'est où il ya cette france qui vraiment
décroche et on le sait depuis des années
ça fait 20 ans que c'est le cas parce
qu'on désindustrialise parce que des
métiers disparaissent parce que les gens
sont renvoyés vers les périphéries
encore une fois parce qu'ils peuvent
plus vivre dans les centres-villes et il
ya aucune réponse structurelle ni la
france ni de l'europe d'ailleurs il y
avait un autre une autre aspiration
important 10g jaune c'était la justice
fiscale cette justice sur les taxes
aujourd'hui voyons où elle l on a encore
scandales financiers les pans de rappeur
on sait très bien que les ultra-riches
cash large andré paradis fiscaux les
gouvernements et les instances
internationales ne font rien pour aller
chercher cet argent même aux états unis
pour taxer 700 contribuables
ultra-riches joe biden a du mal à faire
des lois donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
vrai problème de justice fiscale il est
important et et cette explosion des
inégalités ne peut aller que vers
davantage de violence je suis tout à
fait d'accord et le premier jaune c'est
qu'il voit lui soumet les taxes mais
celui des impôts il n'en voit jamais le
retour six ans j'ai été oublié j'ai été
mis à l'écart et cet argent par ailleurs
soit dans les centres villes soit dans
les banlieues soient dans les quartiers
mais j'avais journée le retour moi même
alors que je continue à payer des taxes
pendant que les ultra-riches fond de
l'optimisation fiscale commise
après les crises successives de l'union
européenne comme le récent accrochage
avec la pologne les difficultés de
création d'une politique commune sur le
co vide ou sur les prix de l'énergie de
plus en plus de voix s'élèvent pour
fustiger le poids de l'union européenne
et son impact sur la souveraineté
nationale alors est-il réellement
possible et souhaitable comme certains
candidats à la présidentielle le
promettent de renégocier les traités
européens
la souveraineté nationale est elle
réellement remise en cause par les
règles de lieux mais commençons d'abord
par une première question messieurs la
france pourrait-elle réformer l'union
européenne tout seul
non évidemment la france peut pas
réformer seule l'union européenne elle
peut en partir ce qui serait très
compliqué mais ce qui est une
possibilité elle peut s'allier avec
d'autres pays qui pour l'instant
subissent aussi les foudres de la
commission européenne j'aimerais juste
qu'on lise et compense cette phrase
d'ursula von der leyen dont on sait pas
qui est cette dame fin on sait qui c'est
n'en sait pas qui l'a nommé parlant de
la pologne nous ne laisserons pas nos
valeurs communes être mises en danger la
commission agira nos traités sont très
claires le droit de l'union européenne
prime sur le droit national y compris
sur les dispositions constitutionnelles
c'est quand même incroyable
souvenons nous qu'en france en tout cas
ça a été appliquée réellement par
nicolas sarkozy après le référendum qui
avait été refusée par 55% des français
donc pour la france c'est scandaleux ça
c'est cette cette phrase mais à dire que
le peuple français ne l'a jamais admise
tout est scandaleux et la france ne
pourra pas seuls réformer l'union
européenne la construction européenne
elle commence sur l'idée de mettre en
commun les ressources et de faire un
marché unique elle est sur une base
économique pourquoi pas après tout on
sort de l'après guerre on a un plan
marshall les etats-unis ont besoin de
faire un tampon face à la menace
socialiste puisque vous aviez le bloc
soviétique qui étaient aux portes de
l'union européenne et on construit un
ensemble économique ça marche avec
d'ailleurs des gens qui viennent et de
l'administration française anciennement
collaborationniste et aussi du parti
nazi le premier patron bien sûr de la
cee il ya tout un débat là-dessus mais a
été un juriste qui a aussi travaillé sur
une union européenne avant à l'époque de
10 clair le problème nazim heures avec
hitler mais le projet européen lui
continue et il a un projet économique
vous avez également tous les pères de
l'europe qui étaient d'abord des
marchands plutôt que des politiques et
on voit bien que la politique est
absence de ce projet européen et c'est
tout le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
a une robe qui s'est transformé en une
sorte de de substrats morale d'autorité
morale c'est à dire qu'il ya des valeurs
communes alors elles restent à définir
c'est la démocratie de marché la
démocratie libérale c'est l'état de
droit évidemment mais c'est des mots
vides des mots valises qui ne permettent
pas de dire ce qu'est l'europe
d'ailleurs l'europe s'est bien gardé de
dire où étaient les frontières pour
prévoir et les élargissements et les
départs successifs présent c'est un
ensemble finalement d'intérêt mais on ne
crée pas de fake aux mains de fée
européen est un pays tel que la france
ne peut rien faire seul et je crois que
le leur c'est de croire que on est plus
fort en étant plusieurs aujourd'hui on
se tire dans les pattes les commission
européenne sont là pour organiser la
concurrence mais rien d'autre et un peu
plus que ça si moi je dirais la
commission européenne est là aussi pour
aller taper les pays qui ne
respecteraient pas des valeurs qui ont
été inventés hier ou avant-hier par les
commissaires européens on sait pas lui
on sait pas ce que c'est c'est à dire la
hongrie la pologne alors que l'on va
leur reprocher d'affaires une loi sur le
la diffusion et la promotion de
l'homosexualité mais au nom de quoi ce
serait contraire aux valeurs de l'union
européenne s'était défini par qui et il
y avait c'est moi je veux revenir sur
l'histoire de l'union européenne vous
avez très bien décrite il y avait
parallèlement à ces marchands il y avait
quand même la volonté d'avoir une âme
européenne qu'on trouvait chez un peu
chez robert schuman qu'on trouve chez
jacques delors rica comme était un grand
promoteur de l'union européenne et qui
parlait il s'adressait aux évêques à la
cathédrale de strasbourg en 99 forcément
il est un escroc chrétien mais lui-même
et un est un chrétien il expliquait
qu'il fallait trouver une âme
spirituelle et une signification à
l'europe sinon on aura perdu la partie
vous pourrez retrouver cette âme et par
ailleurs il expliqué que cette
construction à l'as wihr technocratique
progressant sous l'égide d'une sorte de
despotisme nous éclairer doit se
transfigurer dans un projet porteur de
sens mais qu'il assume le fait que c
était un despotisme doux et éclairé pas
forcément pour dire que ça de voir se
perpétuer mais pour des cons a eu besoin
de faire ça pour expliquer aux européens
qui sont comme ils doivent se comporter
mais à la fonte avec une europe qui est
un gros machin qui nous surveille sans
nous protéger mais je crois que là on
peut on peut revenir même au delà de
jacques delors il faut revenir sur la
philosophie d'habermas associe la
construction européenne le problème
c'est qu'elle elle fait fi de l'histoire
en fait elle elle arrive après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et le choc bien
sûr civilisationnel qui a été la guerre
de 14 on a sacrifié des générations
entières sur le territoire européen et
l'idée c'est de dire l'état nation est
mal on ne peut pas continuer avec ça et
on doit faire une histoire nouvelle a
nommé nouveau une europe nouvelle avec
cette idée d'universalisme d'état de
droit de démocratie de marché qui serait
la fin de l'histoire c'est fukuyama et
ça c'est vraiment habermas c'est aussi
ce que pense emmanuel macron et tous
ceux cette france qu'on appelle les
européistes qui pensent que
l'intégration européenne doit continuer
mais elle ne peut pas se faire sans
histoire je pense que le vrai problème
là où est on est en butte à ce problème
là c'est que le peuple européen il
existe on a des valeurs communes en a
des histoires comme jacques delors était
façade et d'évêques il y a une histoire
commune et religieuses et pas seulement
intra européennes on est aussi un
ensemble géographique qui a dialogué
avec l'autre rive de la méditerranée
avec l'extrême orient avec le proche- et
moyen-orient et ça c'est idiot de faire
comme si c'était un blog complet est
fermé c'est la modernité la post
modernité et qui fait qu' on ne peut pas
incarner l'europe sans valeur et ces
valeurs aujourd'hui d'accord mais il
faut savoir lesquels veulent s est bien
tout le produit redéfinit c'est que
quand vous avez des leaders en europe de
l'est qui disent nous nous avons choisi
des valeurs et elles sont sans doute
réactionnaire à vos yeux et c'est le
christianisme et c'est une certaine
vision de l'homogénéité européenne là
ils sont pointés du doigt comme étant le
camp du mal comme étant hors du des
valeurs européennes la pologne
typiquement d'ailleurs à ce sujet de la
marine le pen et alors on grille de ce
sujet là j'aimerais bien qu'on écoute de
seconde les ménages de sanctions et a
fortiori d'exclusion qui sont d'une rare
violence à l'égard de la hongrie ou de
la pologne témoigne de l'enjeu du débat
qui s'ouvre
j'aime venir union européenne c'est bien
qu'elle joue là son bateau les nations
savent que dans ce débat juridique elles
jouent leur existence
consciente de cette importance je me
suis engagé dès mon élection à réformer
la constitution française par référendum
pour acter le principe de sa supériorité
parce que quel que soit votre rapport
avec marine le pen vous êtes d'accord
sur cette source qu'elle dit l'un sur le
fait que mais cette violence de l'union
européenne qui se manifeste en plus par
des parts des voix économique c'est à
dire si vous n'acceptez pas oui c'est un
amiral et les valeurs qu'on veut vous
imposer pas d'argent c'est comme ça que
ça se joue et c'est ça qui est
scandaleux
c'est à la fois l'union européenne a été
là pour aider ces pays à construire un
état fort pour lutter contre la
corruption aussi dans certains états de
la nouvelle accession mais aujourd'hui
on voit bien que c'est devenu une un
ordre moral et c'est ça qui est
inacceptable l'europe ne peut pas
détenir la morale et politique et
philosophique chaque pays peut
s'organiser de la façon dont il entend
le problème de l'allocution de marine le
pen c'est de faire croire que parce que
on changerait quelques lignes de la
constitution on résoudrait le problème
les traités nous lie toujours donc il va
falloir revenir sur les traités or
comment on fait eh bien il faut être
plusieurs c'est ce que dit emmanuel
macron lui en disant tout simplement
c'est de notre faute l'europe c'est nous
qui le faisons il était un discours
qu'il a fait aux états généraux de la
justice on va l'écouter et là problème
il est là
je suis étonné pour rester pudique
dans nos débats aujourd'hui de voir que
dès qu'il ya un problème nous en
revenons à cette vieille maladie
française qui consiste à dire c'est
drôle mais l'europe c'est nous c'est
nous qui l'avons fait et qui l'avons
choisie c'est nous qui l'avons
construite tous les textes auxquels nous
sommes soumis nous les avons bâti dans
nos discussions puis signer puis ratifié
souverainement je sais que cette affaire
c'est typique de macron à manipulation
non l'europe ce n'est pas nous la preuve
en est le référendum de 2005 il a été
mis à la poubelle et puis c'est le
traité de lisbonne de 2007 qui fait que
l'europe revient par la fenêtre non
c'est une certaine élite qui a décidé
que l'europe s'imposeraient aux peuples
et la preuve on a peur des référendum il
y en a très peu un sur la sphère
européenne et c'est pourtant là où on
devrait remettre de la démocratie dans
le projet européen pour sans doute
qu'ils aient davantage d'adhésion et qu'
il ait quelque part qu'il soit un projet
politique aujourd'hui ça reste un projet
technocratique ça reste un projet moral
et c'est là le danger et ça devient même
un projet ce dos et j'ai monique c'est à
dire qu'on est coincé entre des empires
et nous n'avons pas les moyens d'une
quelconque souveraineté européenne
exactement oui on à l'europe qui nous
empêche de faire des choses et qui nous
aide pas et qui nous protège pas là où
elle devrait et c'est devenu surtout un
projet juridique c'est le professeur
frédéric rouvillois professeur de droit
quand signal qui revenait récemment sur
comment le droit européen a prévalu sur
le droit national et se serait fait en
douce ça commence dans les années 60 ça
commence où le général de gaulle qui
s'aperçoit pas de la chose par un arrêt
rendu par la cour de justice de l'union
européenne qui fait déjà prévaloir le
droit européen sans demander l'avis de
personne ça se joue avec d'autres
d'autres arrêts suivants dans les années
70 80 jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive qu'on en
dise à bien regarder en fait finalement
ce droit prévaut même sur les
constitutions de pays souverains est
tout à fait discutable parce que plus
que discutable est scandaleux d'un point
de vue démocratique et souveraineté
sachant que cette construction a été
anticipée mocratique comme le disait
jacques delors et elle continue de
l'être quand vous avez la nomination à
d'ursula von der leyen à la tête de la
commission européenne personne ne sait
comment ça se passe entre négociateurs
grands pays alors emmanuel macron a
raison de dire que l'europe c'est une
construction des états européens oui
mais des élites des états européens les
peuples eux ont tranché et ils sont
nombreux et je crois que le break site a
été un coup de tonnerre dans cet espace
liquide inquiète l'europe en disant
finalement nous on est une île alors
qu'on va reprendre le large avec bien
sûr il y avait là la peur de voir la
grande bretagne s'effondrer sur
elle-même eux ont pu partir parce qu'il
n'avait pas la monnaie unique le
problème maintenant aujourd'hui c'est
l'intégration telle qu'elle est fun de
manière économique avec la banque
centrale européenne qui décide de faire
de la dette de créer de l'argent magique
l'euro qui est une monnaie qui va avoir
bien des soucis on a vu comment la crise
grecque avait déjà mis en péril à cette
monnaie unique la suite risque d'être
encore plus compliqué et avec une
question pourquoi on reste si c'est pour
payer davantage et récupéré - et aider
des pays qui finalement vont partir dans
quelques années la sortie de l'euro est
très compliqué mais je pense que ce que
disent certains candidats depuis
quelques années et qu'on pourrait sortir
de certains traités l'union européenne
tout en restant dans la zone euro et une
chose possible et serré musan de voir
les candidats à la candidature des
républicains
valérie pécresse guérir temps et surtout
michel barnier qui a été le négociateur
du bric cité qui était avant-hier le
grand thuriféraire de l'union européenne
arrivé en disant non en fait on va
sortir maintenant de certains traités
notamment pour lutter contre
l'immigration on n'arrive pas savoir
quel est son degré de sincérité
livradois la voir en revanche il s'est
bien aperçu que le peuple français
notamment le peuple de droite et une
partie d'ailleurs du peuple de gauche et
souverainistes ne veut plus de cette
europe voir en quoi le nous rend
impuissant 100w aucun moyen de puissance
preuve en est frontex que qu'on nous
vend depuis depuis des années et qui
n'arrivent pas à jouer son rôle je
regarde les moyens soient vraiment
d'organisation soit par manque de
coopération même entre les pays
européens il faut regarder les
compétences de l'union européenne et là
on voit quand même les graves
manquements l'union douanière première
chose déjà on voit que la chine fait ce
qu'elle veut à peu près maintenant en
europe et un peu partout l'établissement
de règles de concurrence alors on a vu
un l'ultra concurrents jusqu'à la
directive pour quelle chaîne et
travailleurs détachés qui ont fait de la
concurrence même au sein du marché du
travail en europe la politique monétaire
bon ça bien sûr on en a parlé avec
l'euro reste à voir la conservation des
ressources biologiques de la mer très
bien alors là il ya quelques pays qui
n'ont pas vraiment beaucoup de côtes
c'est une politique particulière la
politique commerciale commune là encore
et puis la conclusion d'accords
internationaux sous certaines conditions
mais on le voit bien les accords
internationaux encore avantages certains
pays plus que d'autres un des gros
problèmes aussi de cette construction
européenne au delà du fait qu'il ya eu
le psychodrame allemand est de dire on
nous ne devons pas refaire les erreurs
du passé que tout le monde à somatisé en
disant finalement le nazisme n'est pas
que l'erreur d'un pays mais c'est
l'erreur de toute l'europe il ya
derrière aussi la volonté de
reconstruire vite et d'aider justement
l'allemagne à devenir un pays important
sachant qu'à l'époque il y avait deux
allemagnes aujourd'hui on comprend bien
que beaucoup de pays n'ont pas des
intérêts communs notamment dans le
domaine de la défense dans le domaine de
la diplomatie et dans le domaine des
accords internationaux et pourtant on
continue de faire comme s'il y avait un
ensemble
logique européen même économique alors
même qu un pays économiquement pour
l'instant tire les marrons du choqué
l'allemagne depuis vingt ans notamment
quel pays dominent et à faire de
l'europe une sorte de d'empyr ou
d'arrière course et l'allemagne sansan
germanophobie aucune mais c'est vraiment
le pays ils viennent point sens et
l'intérêt de la france c'est que
contrairement à d'autres petits pays où
plus petits pays qui ne pourraient pas
sortir de l'union européenne sans sans
dégâts sans se retrouver largués dans le
grande boucherie de la mondialisation la
france est peut-être le seul pays
maintenant que le royaume uni parti qui
est assez grand et assez puissant pour
s'opposer allemagne pour mona session à
partir sans être sûr de mourir demain ou
sans dégâts gigantesques je pense que
c'est le rôle qu'on devrait avoir mais
c'est parce qu emmanuel macron nous
promet à mon avis avec sa présidence
futur de notre été fait je crois que
vraiment aujourd'hui
j'espère que l'idée la construction
européenne va être au coeur de la
campagne présidentielle parce que il est
question projet et de projets d'avenir
et on ne peut pas continuer à dire que
ceux qui décident d'aller contre la
commission de bruxelles sont dans le
camp du mal il ya une réalité et on ne
peut pas non plus accepter que l'état de
droit tel qu'il est prononcé énoncé par
l'europe assez vide de sens serait
l'alpha et l'oméga de la démocratie
occidentale il ya au delà de ça une
question sur pourquoi on a un des dignes
me pratiquer dans cette construction
européenne et il doit cesser et je pense
que ce sera important d'en faire un
sujet
direction le monde d'après alexis poulin
et jacques de guillebon vous éclaire sur
l'actualité politique de demain avec un
sujet qu'ils ont choisi d'évoquer et
c'est vous jacques qui commençait de
quel sujet avez vous choisi de parler
cette semaine
j'ai choisi de vous parler des
républicains ce parti qu'on a enterré
peut-être un petit peu vite qui demeure
très ancrée dans les territoires et les
régions comme ils disent vrai vu aux
régionales et aux départementales même
si c'est pas tout à fait significatif
qui met du temps à se trouver son
champion on n'est plus comme en 2016 où
on avait trois cadors qui s'affrontaient
juppé sarkozy fillon là on a des seconds
couteaux peut-être mais on voit
bizarrement c'est pas un raz-de-marée
comme ils le disent mais quand même une
augmentation des
adhésions aux républicains depuis depuis
un mois ils sont passés de 80 mille ha à
100 milles à peu près
c'est par cole mais voilà mais c'est un
waterloo non plus comme et l autre et il
espère arriver à 120 milles ce qui
serait à peu près l'étiage de des verts
dans leur dans leurs dernières
consultations donc séparé pas
gigantesque mais pour un parti qu'on
disait mort et enterré peut-être va-t-il
se passer quelque chose et la question
c'est qui sont ces nouveaux adhérents
sont d'anciens adhérents ou est ce que
c'est des nouveaux os qui viennent pour
un candidat particulier ça je ne sais
pas mais je crois qu'il ya quand même un
espace pour les républicains entre
zemmour et macro et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de déçus et des l'un et de
l'autre qui se disent pourquoi pas
reconstruire une droite républicaine qui
serait un peu plus nerveuse un
qu'actuellement un peu plus existantes
aussi et pas seulement dans l'opposition
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de français
de droite qui ne se reconnaissent pas ni
dans la politique d' emmanuel macron ni
dans les propositions d'eric zemmour
donc c'est normal à mon avis que ce
parti attire encore et qu'il y ait un
intérêt par rapport à ça et surtout on
voit en quoi ce parti s'est droitisée
pour aller justement sur les terres de
marine le pen et d'eric zemmour et en
quoi peut-être ça rassure une certaine
frange de la droite qui se croyait
délaissé qui ne voyait que des des
barons partir vers le centre vers
emmanuel macron peut-être sont-ils en
train d'essayer de reconstruire quelque
chose mais on verra ça qu'à descendre ça
prendra du temps c'est lui moi pour le
monde d'après j'ai choisi de parler d'un
rapport
sur l'hôpital qui embarrasse beaucoup
olivier ferrand ministre de la santé
rapporte pourtant sorti par monsieur
delfraissy et les services de l'état
cliff état de 20 % de fermetures de lits
dans les services de l'hôpital public
parfois c'est beaucoup plus et pas
seulement parce que il n'y a pas de
malade il y en a beaucoup
ça ne change pas parce qu'il n'y a
simplement pas de personnel des
démissions en cascade des soignants
qu'on n'arrive plus à former ou à tirer
dans les métiers de la santé malgré le
ségur de la santé les revalorisations
salariales ça ne suffit pas les métiers
du soin n'attire plus personne on manque
de médecins on manque de bras et ce
n'est pas les robots qui vont pouvoir
changer la faire on le voit bien
emmanuel macron lui avec france 2030 il
veut des robots partout il veut de la
téléconsultation partout il veut du
numérique partout or les métiers du soin
et non il faut de l'humain qui s'occupe
des humains et là on est devant un
déficit total et olivier ferrand se
retrouve face à ces mensonges avec un
rapport qu'il n'a du mal à comprendre
aux gens mais ça n'a pas du tout à rien
à voir avec les chiffres de propagande
que je sors chaque jour sur les plateaux
et il demande même à un rapport pour
voir si ce rapport est juste voilà où on
en est en macro ni aujourd'hui on notera
quand même qu'on sort du complotisme
c'est à dire si delfraissy équivalent de
faire un rapport qui va taper olivier
ferrand ça prouve qu'on ne nous montre
pas toute la journée qu'on n'est pas en
train de décliner en démocratie ou bien
malgré nous donc ça on peut déjà noter
c'est quand même une bonne chose les
parieurs ou est ce qu'on voit dans
l'hôpital c'est ce qu'on constate dans
les zones rurales depuis des années
c'est à dire le manque de médecins la
désertification médicale et c'est juste
en train de se transférer dans les
hôpitaux et dans l'est dans les centres
urbains mais comme on le disait tout à
l'heure oui c'est une population ces
soignants comme andy qui est maltraité
gouvernements successifs maltraités
financièrement maltraités économiquement
maltraités même on peut dire moralement
face à dire que les banques de soins
c'est à dire que rien ne les attire qui
s'est pas valorisées personne n'a plus
envie d'y aller on les comprend et la
crise n'a fait qu'ajouter à ça mais
malheureusement cette crise qui aurait
pu être le déclencheur peut être la
mèche qui nous réveille ray ne l'a pas
été on ne voit plus aucune mesure n'a
été prise et que les lits continue à
fermer comme vous le disiez il continue
et d'ailleurs je vois pas comment
les marcheurs qui vont refaire du
porte-à-porte en défendant le bilan des
macros on pouvoir défendre ce bilan sur
la santé ou les services publics ali sur
cinq qui a fermé c'est beaucoup trop
c'est un bilan catastrophique on est là
face à un effondrement un saccage de
l'hôpital public par le ministère et et
encore une fois c'est un petit coup de
côté et le porte parole du gouvernement
de dire c'est pas nous c'est les
gouvernements successifs depuis vingt
ans qu'on a fait du mal ça se change pas
en cinq ans alors à quoi ça sert de
faire à ségur de la santé à quoi ça sert
de vouloir le pouvoir d'avoir un grand
plan à quoi ça sert finalement pour dire
que c'est jamais notre faute et celle
des autres et puis un petit tour et puis
s'en va donc je pense que les français
en ont marre et que ce bilan il va
falloir le défendre et que comme le
disait d'ailleurs une belle macro les
chiffres ne mentent pas et là ça fait
mal au bilan des manuels macron quand on
voit les chiffres et là ce sera pas un
petit tour et puis s'en va ce sera
l'occasion pour emmanuel macron de dire
donnez moi encore le pouvoir pendant
cinq ans et je vous changerez ça et je
vous sauverez l'hôpital ont peu facile
voilà on en parlera de toute façon lors
du prochain épisode au revoir enfin
alexis
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]